this movie exists child actor looks
nothing like a solder counterpart
unsettling scalp sniffing fetish
promotes stalking scene does not include
lap dance high school student has a rear
window poster Uncle Ben picks up
perfectly solved Rubik's Cube and then
puts it back messed up Peter Parker uses
Bing
after Kurt cocking how and why say
surfing the search results inside of an
iframe on the Bing page Oscorp uses
Disney ride narration for exposition
purposes Peters love interest
conveniently also works for the bad guy
non-existent full-color floor-to-ceiling
hologram technology peter bumps into the
one shady dude with papers related to
his father's work peter perfectly mimics
a complicated security touchscreen
gesture after watching from fifty feet
away floor-to-ceiling holograms but no
security cameras peter willingly walks
into a room with hundreds of spiders
skateboard reappears after not having
existed the entire previous sequence
peter uses being again non-existent for
stealing hologram that you can touch
technology more uncle ben lectures about
responsibility long abandoned
underground wrestling ring perfectly
position to give peter costume
inspiration weight is a christmas random
micro trip and a cell phone equals
police scanner why all these random
citizens gathering outside the police
station peter uses Bing for a third
freaking high magic card or key code
decoder gizmo
Peter somehow knows exactly which car
this dude is gonna steal supporting role
given to see Thomas Howell but not Bruce
Campbell spider-man takes off his
freaking mask police captain's don't
issue arrest warrants judges too stupid
rat lizard puppet ridiculous Pied Piper
lizard effect property of Peter Parker
plot device what the fuck is up with
these wounds Peter takes off the mask
again cell phone reception in the sewers
evil villain lair conveniently left
unattended custom-built presentation
software created solely to provide
crucial plot details exposition by
police radio use of the phrase mother
hubbard peters mask comes off again
exposition by helicopter pilot during
the crane should be the new jumping the
shirt bro bonding eye contact moment
spider-man is not a parade you do not
need to stop traffic for spider-man
canisters of liquid nitrogen should not
be stored on rooftops worst
secret-identity ever lazy whipping
liquid nitrogen to conveniently lands
right in spider-man's hand the wind
change of heart cliche fatally wounded
but still time for a moral lesson the
funeral invitation red black tie black
umbrellas only these ladders do not
begin to provide enough support or
height for a painting of this scale
you